quando dal menu di un videogioco ti
accorgi c'è uno nudo che molto più magro
di me tra l'altro che sembra era in lega
trasformato in gigante con meno muscoli
la cosa che mi sorprende di tutto questo
che siamo solo nel menu del gioco anzi
nelle opzioni del menu quindi
figuriamoci vabbè nuovo gioco ragazzi
stiamo sua working che in italiano
significa vabbè giochiamo ci mettevano
di squilla l'altro forse non avevo mai
fatto una demo di studio rocco ciao
questo e lucas ciao marco vacca chi
chiama legato brutto pervertito schifoso
aiuto trasformati in gigante zia come
faccio con cauzione ragazzi ha tradotto
sto gioco topo gigio
perché un pelato mia mastrolindo mi ha
legato in macchina come fu così impari a
non avere i capelli se avesse avuto la
mia passari capelli a quest'ora aversi
attutito di brutto il calcio però non ce
l'hai fatta mi spiace 0 beh miglior modo
di liberarsi da una da una legata che io
abbia mai visto magnificata all'inizio
raga
e bellissimo richiamate somali giorgio
così bello ho speso 10 euro spesi bene
porcava
3 cazzo sei andato sono una donna prima
di tutto mi ha già peccato
beretta svedese lascia finalmente il suo
fratello si protrasse dire un po meno la
parola cazzo che è sembrata in me quando
facevo i video all'inizio il mio canale
youtube e libero va bene quindi sono con
mio fratello in cui tutto questo quindi
mastrolindo alla fine era mio fratello
va bene non avevo capito sta roba
beh cosa ciò scusami o le braccia
sporche farvi capire aiuto so sbatte
contro un albero per guardami le braccia
dalle tasche ma dove chi siamo ovunque
ragazzi hanno barre credo che stiano
parlando svedese non morire una cavolata
però ho capito file e letta che credo
sia un insulto in sede sla io voglio un
po
[Musica]
che è successo ma che male sono macchie
sono bacche anno non è una barca non
scada vere che è pruzzo grillo ma
cos'era la carcassa di un animale quella
non ho capito cav h
lo sapevo io tu continua a trovare
un'altra strada va bene ho finalmente ci
siamo staccati da quel pirla un oh che
bello che c'è almeno della civiltà credo
dovevo fare qui
[Musica]
a manca un pezzo addirittura ok bene
questo pezzo dai ragazzi estremo qua
dentro sicuramente troverò qualcuno c'è
una casetta mi sembrava carino
c'è una vacca ok ove usciamo trovato già
così mi serve work salve e lei e rilegga
non è lei
va bene alle 20 fila qualcosa perfetto e
la madonna
mi sa che lei non si lava da un
pochettino di tempo e nel dubbio io vado
via grazie ottima giornata questa per
questa passare in compagnia aggiungerei
è rimasto lì e praga non mi ha raggiunto
fa mi fai la cortesia di non rompermi
trequarti di palle per favore vieni
militari di qua schiarisci ti la gola
usa tanto un verde che fa bene che è
rimasto lì vai vai vai vai dentro una
chiave tua macchina che non ha le ruote
ma in qualche modo non posso e che devo
fà qua aiuto leva levati la cavalca fai
un po schifo al bene però va beh ciao è
stato ora madonna dove vada a finire e
subacquea la tizia aiuto la macchina era
un generatore per la scatola va bene da
un ascensore del 2018 ragazzi
[Musica]
questa è linsday sterling
no sta facendo quello salve ma anche se
una c'è una nuda sarà eccole relegare
lui
ciao e rennes che suona il violino bene
ci vorrebbe la sigla nata collegata con
titans non ad angelino nicchia come
usare huber ragazze non so quanti
chilometri ho fatto amica il
frecciarossa può accompagnare solo
economy spiega dove sto andando il mio
fratello è morto se hai mangiato un
coccodrillo treno papa allora faceva
veramente freccia rossa del carrello
sicuro perché spiegami come fa un treno
a passare sul ponte di legno
se non fosse che del morto mio fratello
ci sono delle miniere qua vicino
immagino sarà la tua madre morta in sé
volta nei boschi mi chiami sono cagato
questa vi sono veramente creato in mano
illuminati con piega infilato la mano è
avvertito anche tu
[Musica]
pietro mi spiega su ciò colpisce cosa
non deve parlare esattamente comunque
non mi sa che io ci avevo giocato una
demo di sta roba
non vorrei dire una cagata realpower è
inutile che giochi per fiaschi giochi
per bambini gioca questo che per veri
uomini non a quelle robe che non fanno
paura porca vacca questo rumore
[Musica]
mastrolindo di sta cippa di minchia
dimmi
si è accorto anche tu che c'è una bestia
qua gigante che somiglia un po a pietro
non so se l'hai vista tutto
meno male che abbiamo ritrovato mio
fronte almeno quello perché sennò si è
messo a correre è scemo problemi a far
da lo guardava uno sgambetto a niente se
ne sa che è un po un po scemo e
mostruose complimenti grazie delle tue
perle fratello senza di te non so come
farei e dove la cappa di stop e lato
davanti agli occhi per tutto il video
ma jean louis elevate
ti prego mangiati lui mangiati noi
mangiati lui
ho fatto bene
no il pelato
datemi dei cerotti ti fa male eh lo so è
un po come significa di s.pietro ad oggi
tira tira tira
no niente l'inter va bè ragazzi di
questa situazione è più che chiaro che
cosa io devo fare devo rallegrarlo in
qualche modo allora fratello ci sono
situazioni peggiori
ad esempio potresti fare un video in
collaborazione con pietro è morto è
morto perché non sopportava l'idea bene
ha sofferto il giusto ed era pelato
bakhtar guardiano ok ma poi 15 che c'è
un guardiano qui salve signor guardiano
guardia è morto mio fratello mi dà una
mano per cortesia pasqua aprire anzi è
la madonna che bello jury chechi e
apporto vabbè voce la mappa ho trovato
una chiave fighissimo ma c'è il telefono
di governo in siano noi siamo qua park
iii che è invece la torre dell'orologio
che il fabbro ecm intimissimi i piccoli
di frey a ponte levatoio e poi qua c'è
la sala dell'arma va bene in giù c'è il
bene dei ragazzi usciamo direi che
possiamo dare alla torre dell'orologio
che non ho capito bene dov'è
telefono
arrivo ci sono gli alberi a me la sto
ricordato adesso la demo piacevano sti
alberi bruttissimi aiutami è così buio
potevo che ti porta una luce dobbiamo
arrivare con un fiammifero arriverò col
fiammifero dopo prometto albero capisci
di aver bevuto troppo quando inizia a
fare promesse agli alberi maron roux
carmen telephone c'è tra tradotti in
cellulare va bene se non vedo uno
smartphone in casa vale ragazzi con cui
non ho questo episodio so che vi lascio
sempre sulle spine però il gioco è
carino ma se mi piace anche a chelsea
scadere ci vediamo a un posto da ragazzi
[Musica]